soaked saffron in warm water  saffron is the most expensive spice in  the world made from the dried stigma of  crocus flowers but even a pinch gives a  fantastic taste and a wonderful color  next separate three eggs put the yolks  into a mixing bowl  add Dijon mustard  finely chopped garlic  the drained saffron  and a squeeze of lemon then mix  whisking constantly add oil slowly it  won't take forever  for perfect flavor use half olive oil  and half vegetable oil the mayonnaise  comes together season  a smooth thick consistency means it's  done  top with saffron  Rich delicious and perfect with  everything from Seafood to sandwiches  and chips